Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American supernatural drama film
called “Nine Days.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie is set in a dystopian world where
unborn souls are tested for 9 days. If the
souls pass the tests, they are given the chance
to live the real world. However, the ones that
do not pass the tests, perish forever. The ones
that eventually get to live in the real world,
have no memory of this interview either.
A man named Will who lives in an isolated house
in the middle of an unknown desert is the arbiter
of souls. Will judges souls and decides which
ones get to inhabit the bodies of living beings.
He interviews souls for a chance to be born in
the real world. Not all candidates make the cut
but Will gives them each an experience of their
choosing before their existence is erased forever.
The only eternal company Will has is a man named
Kyo, a supervisor who makes sure Will selects the
best candidate and assists him with the process.
Before becoming an evaluator for unborn souls,
Will previously lived as a normal human, but
Kyo has never got to live as a living being.
Will spends most of his time watching and taking
notes on a multitude of old fashioned television
screens, each of which displays the life of a
different individual that Will previously
selected. Among all the souls he has chosen,
a 28-year old violin prodigy named Amanda is
his favourite. One day, while on her way to a
concerto, Amanda drives very fast on the highway
and crashes into an overpass, resulting in her
death. Will is devastated by her death and
watches old videos of hers for comfort.
However, Will doesn’t get much time to
mourn Amanda’s death and the following day,
new candidates begin arriving to interview
for the vacancy Amanda left behind. The
candidates include Kane, Anne, Alexander, Mike
and others. The interview lasts for nine days,
during which Will would test their
personalities and character. He asks
the candidates simple questions about life and
has them take notes on what they like or dislike
about the lives of others who were chosen.
On the first day, Will briefs the candidates about
the whole process before starting the interview.
Some candidates are more curious than others. Kane
asks Will the difference between being here and
being alive. When Will reveals that any feeling,
sensation, emotion is much less intense here than
in real life, Kane asks him how he is sure about
that and Will is forced to admit that he has
the experience of living as a person. Curious,
Kane asks what Will achieved as a living person
but Will shuts him down, saying he can’t divulge
any more personal details. Everyone answers the
question in their own way. After finishing the
interviews, Will and Kyo get on with their daily
tasks. Later that evening, the last candidate
Emma shows up late for the interview. Will is
annoyed by Emma’s tardiness but Kyo convinces
him to let her give the interview. Emma is just
as inquisitive as Kane and she asks if Kyo is
Will’s boss but Kyo quickly corrects her and jokes
that if he was he would never hire Will. Emma also
learns that Kyo has never been alive.
Will then asks her the same moral dilemma
question but Emma refuses to answer because in
both instances her son dies. Will tells her that
she must answer the question because that’s how
the question is supposed to be. Emma puts forth
her own question and asks if that’s how the
question is or that’s how cruel the world is.
Emma and Will both refuse to answer each other's
question and the interview comes to an end.
The next day, Will gives the selected
candidates a tour of the house,
including the control room from where Will and Kyo
keep an eye of the previously selected candidates.
He gives the candidate a task to observe people
on the TV and make notes on a living being of
their choice. While observing a living being, Will
notices Mike drawing on his notebook. When Will
asks to see it, Mike is initially hesitant
but eventually allows Will to see his art.
It is a beautiful sketch of a beach.
Later, Will goes through each of their
notebooks and assesses them. All of them have
written about one specific moment of their choice,
except Emma, who has written about a little bit
of everything. He then individually returns their
notebook back in person. Will advises Emma
that she could be more selective. However,
Emma can never be bound by anyone. She asks him
if the candidates he selected remember him. Will
answers in a negative but he also mentions Amanda
momentarily remembering him in her childhood.
Meanwhile, Kane asks Will if there’s any
area in which he should work on. However,
Will tells him not to think that way. Will says he
doesn’t want Kane to do what Will thinks is right,
he wants Kane to do what he deep down feels
is right. Not satisfied by his response,
Kane points out how Will is going to judge him
in the end anyway and asks Will to tell him
the rules so he could play the game better.
As expected, Will doesn’t reveal the rules and
he gives the candidates new assignments. He asks
the candidates to pick a moment they didn’t like
from what they saw on the screen.
After examining their answers,
Will decides to eliminate Mike. A tearful Mike
asks what he did wrong but Will gives him his
same standard answer. Will tries to comfort him
and commends him for living every second there
with intensity and honesty before asking
him to choose a moment that he wants to
experience from what he saw on the TV.
Later that night, Emma overhears Will and Kyu
working in the middle of the night. After learning
that they are working to give Mike a special
farewell, Emma offers to help. While working, Kyu
shares that if given a chance, he would love to
yell like Tarzan from the top of a mountain. Emma
then asks Will which moment he would choose but an
irritated Will doesn’t have time for her questions
and tells her to just focus on the work.
After finishing the work, Kyu tells Emma that Will
is the only interviewer who gives his candidates a
chance to experience a real world moment. He also
reveals that when Will was alive, he was too good,
kind and sensitive. Will was talented
but struggled to fit into a world that
was different from him. He had so much
love in him but no one to give it to.
The next day, Will checks the assignment of the
remaining candidates. Kane tells him about the kid
named Rick who is a frequent target of bullies. He
continues that he doesn’t like the fact that Rick
doesn’t fight back more than the fact that other
children bully Rick. Kane says that if he was
in Rick’s place, he would hit the bullies back.
When Will questions him if he justifies violence,
Kane replies that self defense is justice.
When it is Emma’s turn, she describes a guy that
hates himself. She says that the guy thinks he
is a failure and everything he does is worthless
and shameful. Emma says she emphasizes with the
guy for having gone through so much to the point
that he just wants to feel nothing anymore.
She further adds that the numbness may make
him feel safe but it is also poisoning what’s left
of him. She says that deep inside the man knows it
too. Will realises that Emma is describing
him but stops short of acknowledging it.
He says that the man she is describing sounds
irreparable. Emma quickly responds that the man
thinks he is irreparable but she believes that
there’s still something left inside him.
Will then excuses himself to bid Mike goodbye.
With the help of Kyu, Emma follows him to a
secret room where Will gives his candidates their
final experience before they disappear forever.
Emma watches in astonishment as Mike experiences
the beach Will created for him. Will then sits
with a tearful Mike as he gets lost forever.
Afterwards, an emotional Will returns to the TV
room and sits with Emma. He tells her that when he
was alive he used to be a part of a theatre group
in highschool. He reveals he didn’t have
any friends and he once gave a theater
performance that made him feel alive, but
he never pursued his passion after that.
In between taking interviews, Will continues to
watch old videos of Amanda to figure out how she
crashed her car. Will eventually discovers that
Amanda deliberately crashed her car and committed
suicide. Will is shocked by the revelation
and blames himself for sending Amanda into the
cruel world unprepared. As a result, Will starts
fearing a similar fate for a kind hearted Emma.
He gives her tough scenarios but she
always chooses kindness and love.
During the course of the interview, Maria falls
in love with Will. She writes him a letter and
expresses her love. However, Will turns her
down and eliminates her. After experiencing
her final moment, Maria breaks into tears and
pleads with Will to give their love a chance
but Will heartlessly watches her disappear into
the air. All of this leads to Will and Kyu getting
into an argument. Kyu accuses Will of shutting
himself off and confronts him about his intentions
to eliminate a good candidate like Emma. Will
argues that he can’t keep sending flowers to
the real world while other interviewers send pigs
that eat them. They eventually cool down and again
start discussing Amanda. Will admits that just
like him, Amanda must have felt immense pain
that no one could see with their eyes.
Will ultimately decides to burn all of
Amanda’s tapes and move on. Moreover,
over the course of the next few days,
most of the candidates are dismissed for various
reasons, such as self-consciousness and lack of
respect for suffering. The candidates are narrowed
down to two: Emma and Kane. On the ninth day,
Emma finally meets Kane. They both are
contrasting in character. Emma is carefree,
kind, and sees the best in people, Kane is more
pessimistic, recognizing the evil in the world
and showing resolve to fight back against it.
Over dinner, the two get to know each other.
Will makes the two sit in a room together
and asks them to tell each other why they
shouldn’t be alive. This naturally makes
Emma uncomfortable and she walks out.
Later, despite Kyo recommending that Will
pick Emma, Will chooses Kane to be born.
Will offers Emma a last experience and she
writes something down on a paper. However,
Emma writes something which Will can’t seem to
do. Will asks her to choose something else but
she declines a last experience. As Emma prepares
to leave, Will sees Kane off to the real world.
Emma asks to see Will one last time but he decides
not to see her off. Kyo offers to be with her in
her last moments but she declines and opts to
walk across the desert until she disappears.
After Emma leaves Will finds a note from Emma
where she thanks him for everything. She expresses
regret for all the things he went through because
of which he doesn’t allow himself to feel alive.
She tells him that she has written all the
beautiful memories she made in the last 9 days
all over the house. She asks him to not take
those moments for granted before signing off.
Puzzled, Will looks around and finds them written
all over the house. Those moments are a day at
the beach, Kyo yelling off a cliff, Laughing
with Kane, a bicycle ride, and many others.
Will suddenly realizes that those were
indeed happy moments. Feeling regret,
he runs out after Emma. He eventually catches
up to her and passionately recites selections
from Walt Whitman’s Song of Myself, thanking her
for daring him to allow himself to breathe.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel
out. Thanks for watching.